you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution
here
i have a juvenile chimpanzee the top of
the skull is very round and smooth and
here i have a mature chimpanzee
and he has this beautiful
sagittal crest on the top
that's just you know kind of like a bone
mohawk
yeah it totally is in the gorilla that's
just
absolutely extreme huge crest up here
and in both of these animals and chimps
and gorillas that does not exist when
they're young in fact i've got a
this here is a baby gorilla and his
skull is shaped just like a humans
actually
so the
sorry this is this one's a chimpanzee
i've got a gorilla over there
but
this fact that
bones are constantly changing shape is
spectacular not all animals can do this
is that correct
uh sort of so not all animals
can do a certain other type of
remodeling so we can get into it um
there's different kinds of remodeling
one called one that most people think of
which actually causes most of the
remodeling in our body and it's called
osteonor remodeling and all that means
is it's led by osteons it's actually led
by your blood vessels invading the bone
and carrying cells with them that
destroy and rebuild bone we'll talk
about that more in detail because that's
the one that does a lot of heavy lifting
in our skeleton
but the less known one and that's what
my publication was about which is why i
talk about it a little bit more often is
perry lacuna remodeling which so
basically osteocytes bone cells live in
these little caves
and they can remodel the cave that they
live in and the cave is obviously made
of bone because they live in our bones
and they monitor our bones and they you
know check out if there's too much
stress or not enough calcium and if your
bone needs remodeling they're the ones
that send out the alarm for
these cells to come and do remodeling
but what they actually can do themselves
is that they can take away calcium and
phosphate from the walls and recirculate
it back into the system and this is
happening on a cellular scale it's super
super tiny so all they're doing is just
etching the outside of their environment
and sending that but when you consider
that aside from like neurons and other
cell types like osteocytes are the
longest lived
and very numerous cells in our skeleton
uh it does have an impact on your
metabolism so that's one type of
remodeling but
this the really interesting and um and
the one that we can see very often is
this osteonol remodeling this type which
basically forms all these blood vessels
coming through
your bone and they carry with them at
the very front of them they carry
osteoclasts so that's how they bury
through the bone they basically do these
like mold tunnels
through your bone and then they send out
osteoblasts on the outside and they
rebuild and that's how you end up
remodeling old bones so say you had an
old wall they tunnel through that old
wall and then rebuild on their way out
and they do it in like a really
interesting like zipper motion so you
open it like it's open on one side and
they start to close it off as they go
along
so
yeah and and that's how we
we basically get a new skeleton
every seven to ten years until you're
like 25 or something along those lines
and it depends on the type of bone and
it's just continuously recycling
continuously renewing one of your
questions is how do you get
you know crests on one
animal and not the other or over
ontogeny as they're growing up
why are they getting crusts yeah yeah so
yeah let's talk about the crust first
because it seems to be pressure from the
muscles the chewing muscles that causes
the crest to grow because they start out
when they're young they have the muscles
just on the side of the head and as they
go through puberty those muscles enlarge
and they creep up they get so big they
creep up the skull and it seems like
somehow by pulling on the skull that
triggers the cells to be like oh we need
to build more bone here and that that
process is just mysterious to me
we know our muscles have an influence on
our bone
that's why you know
if you work out you get denser bones if
you go to space and you're not using
your muscles against your bone as much
you get
less dense bones
so
we know that the two talk to each other
what you're looking at in that crest is
a muscle attachment site
and it's known that muscle attachment
sites will get more robust uh based on
pressure so kind of like you said it's
they're not exactly pushing up the bone
and they're not exactly pulling at the
bone
but what they're doing is even if you
have like the tiniest little crest and
you have a little bit of muscle that's
attached to it as it's being as the
muscle is working you know flexing and
loosening up and flexing and loosening
up it actually puts pressure on the
periosteum there the thin layer that
covers all our bones and has the living
cells in it
and that tells the bone hey this is an
important spot make it bigger make it
rougher so we can attach more things so
that's how you get some of those crazy
crests on those primates but it's also
how you get really intense attachment
sites on arms and
legs and stuff
in fossils and that's how we reconstruct
muscular the musculature of extinct
animals we follow these
areas these areas that are bumpy and
lumpy and that's how we know okay this
is bumpy and lumpy because a muscle
pulled on it a whole lot
so now we know that that must connect to
something here that must connect to
something here so that's
it's a good question because
muscle attachment sites are incredibly
important
yeah if you were looking at a human
skeleton could you tell if the person
was a weightlifter versus you know
regular joe would that would that
actually show up
it would it definitely would would i be
able to tell you'd probably want to talk
to a um
like anthropologist
just because i'm not as familiar with
human anatomy but yes you definitely can
there's even papers that they look at
skeletons of like people from medieval
times and look at the robustness of the
ephemera the like bones and how thick
the cortical bone is and they can tell
okay this person was you know working
hard labor uh and that you know
corresponds with the type of burial we
found them in and that kind of stuff
does show up in your bones your
skeletons record our lives i read a
paper a long time ago years ago
they found
a broken bone that had healed
on a human
and
there was a certain structure in the
face that made it look like for years
they had this painful wincing expression
on their face that could actually show
it actually showed up in the bones
when someone had is in pain they move
their face in a certain way
and that can that tugs on the bone a
little bit and they said they can
actually read that in the face i don't
know
how um like disputed that claim is but
they they're like oh yeah this person
was in misery their whole life isn't
that awesome oh god
i mean that's yeah that's uh that's
ancient osteology for you i kind of say
the same thing a lot about animals like
oh look at this pathology like that it's
so cool this animal lived its whole life
then you realize you're like not the
nicest thing
but um i don't i don't know about that
particular paper especially because in
the face the human face a lot of the
muscles are so fine and they're smooth
muscles that's like they're not these
like strong tugging muscles i really
wonder if
they would make that kind of impact on
osteology but i wouldn't i wouldn't rule
it out i'd have to read the paper but
that sounds really cool
so after my conversation with yara i
looked this up
it turns out that i did not read about
this in a paper
i watched it in a nova documentary on
pbs
and
scientists do not agree you can't
actually tell someone's facial
expressions
unfortunately based on their skull
but in the nova special they did think
you could and they said this they say in
the case of kenobi man evidence for
severe injuries suggested that the man
lived many of his 40-plus years in
frequent if not chronic pain he had a
bunch of broken bones he had indications
that he got stabbed with a spear all
sorts of stuff prominent muscle markings
above the chin and beneath the eye
sockets confirmed this revealing a face
held in an expression of determined
endurance
for this reason our approximation shows
the weariness of a middle-aged man in
perpetual discomfort that's a pretty
cool sculpture
but their claim is contradicted by this
paper facial reconstruction anatomical
art or artistic anatomy which goes over
the what we can and cannot trust in
these facial reconstructions these are
really cool by the way it's pretty
impressive what can be done but you
cannot get enough detail to figure out
what type of facial expression a person
was making during their life
so here we have this huge on the top of
the skull here
we've got this huge crest which
so what you're saying is that this
it's the it's the tissue on the outside
of the bone that is getting that signal
and is trying to
grow in accommodation to that well
that's it for this clip but don't worry
i post clips regularly and every
thursday i post completely fresh content
make sure you're subscribed
liking and commenting is also welcome